what do I look like look like fat pants
up but fresh handsome boy for this video
my mom is dressing me or a whole week
we're gonna go to a mall my mom's gonna
choose five outfits for me no need to
wear every day go to work
she doesn't like all the flowers yeah a
flower cheesy I know good honey culture
never where did one okay you need to
wear the color signing only one color by
the way that's a rooster in the
background so don't mind it when you
won't need I will try to walk along
because I want to protect you
empty if you will call and you're ready
now and you cop always the Colo attitude
for you keep one we did a similar thing
two years ago where she chose one outfit
for me wow you look handsome
these are different fastened for yoke
I'm just hoping that it's not too bad I
think you'll love it what way okay
my mom hasn't chosen my clothes since I
was in Middle School I go shopping
weekend one not gonna go to a yokel oh
wow we filter see and feel hungry I've
been there but maybe you don't wanna
keep the baby damn life nah baby kind of
life so very hard to do I hope you like
it
you commit me your your we're okay I
should be talking because at night
really cold you go out in society week
that's for running walking the one row
to take time remember the time for go
home for sleep love letter I think that
good meaning
nothing man it looks shiny it's okay
baby boy outfit you kind of reminded me
of like a really cool sixteen year old
or someone that's in like America's Best
Dance Crew
you think that I would not wear this
these are you hunger
you think it looks good when mom turns
is she's like for the office
I wouldn't think the word office I would
be like you're about to go hike grab it
I feel super hot right now I can't wait
to slip into shorts I'm not used to
wearing sweats and like this hoodie all
day long thick cotton material people
have opinions all over the place doesn't
feel a lot younger cooler okay they look
nice and huh
a color line like purple and look like
in my open game I think the name it la
looks strong huh
yeah look John have the hair really
intelligent like a pretty cool sign that
I never addressed myself in what is this
where's just good to go out to something
and go to work so versatile oh and I
look like a teenager
anything I like I think you're very
color-coordinated this is like a
raspberry ice cream
or I think you look younger actually got
a similar color of sweater I've never
won this color in my life I like it I'm
not used to expressing myself in such
loud colors kind of like a fun side of
me that my mom pulled down childhood
side of me that I've not gotten in touch
with in a while I'm pleasantly surprised
I would probably wear this again I
always hang where the flow thing it
looks strong black pan I think almost
matter flows weather and that's some
work I think it the good meaning to it
mean for Christian too far away I don't
see it but I think you don't worry
it got me Nick very well
and some see john-boy what the semi
turtleneck is this I've never worn this
collar ever in my life I'm normally very
particular with the type of hat that I
wear I usually have a specific shape
that I like and this is not it it makes
my head too flat wait till you see this
text also looks like prescription I'm
reading it backward in Asia you know how
those memes it'll say like cuss words
with flowers around it it just doesn't
matter it's just words and fun obviously
the words on air don't matter
okay I never see this I definitely like
you switch I really like your prophet
it's you you've been looking at what a
like conservative college kid you
definitely look more like voyage managed
yeah seeing you this khaki pants is
definitely like an asian mom thing Asian
moms always like put on some khakis
if I saw you I'd be like well that
person's wearing fun car I mean I'm also
wearing like a muffin sweater alone
color different from what what do I
normally wear neutral colors which one's
more stylish I think your mom's clothes
more stylish
I think canes about it your mom did a
really good job it's color on you is
everything yeah you need to wear this
color more often you don't really do
like pops of color
I didn't realize people notice I'm
starting to think that my mom might be
more fashionable than I am because I'm
gonna Instagram photos that I posted
have three times the lights that my
normal photos would get look at Kane my
hot boy how long she live it soldier
flower and I have the same max color
inside tracer khaki pants dress look
Lionel
90 no year your name in lucky me looking
good the outside pumpkin fair nice okay
look your hot boy now I like the jacket
little scooter it looks like something
you would wear yeah Mac I mean white
yeah come on them there
oh man look I could get out we're gonna
go there yeah but a day is not that I
would weigh yourself are you back in
college again
oh very fancy man
the Sausalito dr. pan and sort it color
man I took the watch for him very
signing everybody they hang you a hang
some today I'm going to a friend's
birthday party today this is a hundred
percent something my dad would wear this
pattern this polka dot pattern I've
actually never had a real watch before
I've had an Apple watch but like I've
never actually had a legit watch I look
like a net this pair of shoes pretty
simple and clean good job what do you
think mom you know oh so ain't some boys
yes I like you okay what do you think
about the watch you go out with your
friend they a surprise you because you
never go out we not I'm actually
surprised that mom is a quite stylish
very hip it's very shocking I picked for
you I feel it perfect I was actually
very surprised literally none of the
clothes she chose I would have chosen
for me now but after wearing it there
were definitely items that I would wear
again one pound so it looks dong and one
pair Lopez I'm Roy Oh Dominic good
update it's been a few weeks since I
filmed with my mom what's wild is that I
had no idea this whole experience would
impact my style so much literally if you
look at my Instagram I have a completely
new look my wardrobe is completely
different I had no idea that in my 20s
my mother would refresh my wardrobe
what started getting into watches I
started wearing different types of hats
just more color in general jumping over
that hurdle about like this is not me I
look awkward in it the fact that I did
it and things were okay now I feel a
little bit more during this video that's
probably impacted my style the most out
of all the videos that I've done so
thank you mom let me know which one is
your favorite outfit which one should I
continue wearing more would you let your
mom dress you for a week you're welcome
yeah that's it bye bye bye bye
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]